I have here a U.S. dollar coin.
It has two sides, one showing a head and one showing what's called tails.
In probability, I'm giving a description of this coin, and I'm making data.
We just make data.
[sound of coin spinning]
So if we look at the coin, it came up heads.
So I just made a data point of flipping the coin once, and it came up heads.
Let me do it again.
[sound of coin spinning]
And--wow! It came up heads again.
So my new data is .
And you can see how it relates to the data we studied before
when we talked about histograms and pie charts and so on.
Let me give it a third try.
[sound of coin spinning]
And, unbelievably, it comes up once again heads.
So let me ask a statistical question to test your intuition.
Do you think if I twist this coin more frequently will it always come up heads?
And say I try to twist it as fairly as I possibly can.